how come nobody takes me seriously all
right
hey there bill exclamation point
well maybe come on too strong everybody
thinks you're weird I'm a 23 year 23
year old male I am a musician
and been working retail Bed Bath and
Beyond I thought retail was close you'd
look lovely in this bathroom for the
last three and a half years lately I've
been pondering heavily on the fact that
my whole life that my whole entire life
nobody has ever taken me seriously I'm a
pretty comical guy I'd say I'm not
saying I cracked the greatest gut
splitting jokes in the West in the West
how adorable
he's 23 ANCA do the most gut splitting
in the West I love this guy this guy
would return your wallet hey by the way
somebody hit my car I had it parked in
the parking lot and the [ __ ] wait
till I came down gave me all the [ __ ]
is there's some good people out there
you know there really a shout out to
that person who I'm gonna pay for cuz
you were a good guy anyways but I do
have a dry sense of humor and most of
the time joking with every interaction
I'm in I love to laugh and make people
laugh what can I say but the thing is oh
man this guy I don't know
he's either just a [ __ ] great guy or
he's sitting on something and half the
mountains gonna blow off one day but the
thing is ivory capped and replayed every
moment in my head I can think of where
somebody shot down any idea I had for
something oh god she thinks she's gonna
have the mohawk any day are you talking
to me you don't respect my ideas
numerous occasions when I've given a tap
I've been given a task at a job and my
peers automatically talk to me like I'm
some kind of [ __ ] simpleton dude I
think you're just too nice and I think
you also say things like crack the best
jokes in the West and they think that
you're a simple person I think you're
really wholesome person you know it is I
you're not jaded and you're probably
working with a bunch of dicks and they
think they can get over on you so
unfortunately you're gonna have to get a
little dirt on you you have to take
someone down to the mat you just kind of
have to where they're not gonna respect
you and also people often say that they
can't picture me mad I know he's
wholesome or is this the guy in the news
like he was the nicest guy we know we
never saw it coming
all of my managers at all of my jobs
have always kind of picked on me -
you're not sticking up for yourself and
I'd be completely honest I know this is
something I've struggled with my whole
life but it's a little hard to put into
words now how I'm feeling about this
yeah dude yeah you've been picked on and
you're one of those guys rather than
being an [ __ ] - you're trying to like
if you I act this way if I act cool
maybe everybody will be cool and people
will stop [ __ ] with me I did that I
tried that didn't work for me look at
the angry [ __ ] lunatic what I was
sitting on
that's true I think I feel that I've set
this expectation for everybody that I'm
always in a positive and joking move so
whenever I want to be taking seriously I
don't get that in return I yeah I'm
tellin you dude you gotta you gotta
break some eggs here to get the omelet
going I think I'm sure my own just
within the law don't want to send you
down personally it breaks a mint not
gonna tell you that what this is being
filmed so they said see somewhat I'm not
a gun guy it was I was trying to member
how you [ __ ] I'm sure my own
personality has brought this upon myself
I know you haven't actually really liked
guns by the way I just scared shitless
of them because I don't know what I
think about I know you haven't known me
my entire life and now you know and your
noise like no anti-gun you are late at
night when you hear a noise you're like
I should have been a gun guy I'm sure my
own personality has brought this upon
myself I know you haven't known me my
entire life and see how I handle it but
just seeking a little wisdom here I had
tried being shorter with people and just
a tad douchier to see if that would work
I did all of this I've done this I've
been when you're AK and I don't feel
that's an effective method yeah you
don't want to be a [ __ ] if you have any
general advice on this kind of thing
anything would help
love the podcast love you stand up thank
you and go [ __ ] yourself yeah what you
need you know what I would try to do sit
down and just start to write about
yourself don't do it on the internet cuz
someone's gonna find it alright just
write down in a notebook what am I
feeling what do I want what makes me sad
you got to get in touch with what's
going on with you and then I don't know
I don't know I kind of did that a lot of
anger came out and then it overly came
out and then what I would literally
would have to do was when I was calling
somebody up to have a confrontation I
would literally have to write the points
I wanted to make and before I made the
phone call I swear to God I would I drew
smiley face like don't get angry and I
you know I'm still [ __ ] working on it
so I think what you're working on a lot
of people are going through you're only
23 you know I didn't I didn't learn how
to have a confrontation and stick up
myself well into my early 30s and it's a
great skill to develop you can totally
turn around it's not like you're tone
deaf and then you got to go sing a song
this is just learning how to confront
people just go baby steps and maybe you
know maybe there's somebody will you go
buy food and they're a little little
flippant with you no no don't don't get
arguments in public that's a bad example
sorry I don't know you're a good guy you
know I don't know it just just I would
start with that and then maybe I would
go into therapy and figure out what's
going on with yourself and and just take
it from there and just you know
gradually work your way up take anything
else anything else that's it takes a
while to get good at something so just
don't beat yourself up all right
and yeah [ __ ] all those people that that
who do that when they see a nice guy
like you who says all of those things
that make people laugh I hope in a good
way that they then go and take advantage
of you